[Music]  inch basic 11g brute who them to them  [Applause]  yeah hey that's a deal  this is the marketplace in yerevan ji  guru buddha  [Applause]  mmmm Johnny  [Applause]  who's this it looks like a little bundle  of some sort of twig glad you're here  okay tell him we wish to buy dried  apricots for your family back home even  though the keys are mine  you know you're not really minding the  store let's keep awake me do whatever  they want back to business so while  we're getting is the apricots  do you know any Armenian men who are  looking for a beautiful they're  everywhere they take off the minute  there's a commitment this I know this is  my food this is the food of my people  Armenian viagra yeah oh my god  right I'm feeling things I haven't felt  in years I will be coming more viagra  [Laughter]  the local creep huh hey in an hour I  won't be able to hug you  [Applause]